each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my great pleasure today to
introduce Jan ciam who is graduating
with her PhD from Stanford University
Jan is fairly unique in the universe she
is a computer scientist / ethnographer
so she sort of knows the business of
software development from from both
sides from having participated in it and
from having observed it so today she's
going to be sharing some of her latest
findings from her ethnographic studies
and with that here's Jim okay um thank
you as I mentioned I'm a doctoral
student at Stanford University I'm in
the department of management science and
engineering over there and I wanted to
talk a little bit about my background
and kind of where I stand before I got
into my more technical portion of the
presentation because as Rob said i
understand i'm actually somewhat unusual
relative to most the people you see here
so my doctorate in organization studies
oh I also have a master's degree in a
bachelor's degree in computer science
all from Stanford I've been there for 10
years getting a little sick of it
actually betta so what is organization
studies it's not it's sort of an
interdisciplinary field sort of a small
sub field so not people often don't know
what it is like when I tell people what
my PhD is and they often have no clue
what that means what it is is it sort of
sits between sociology and management
most organization studies groups are
actually inside business schools so
Stanford's already a little bit weird
and that mine is in what is actually the
industrial engineering department so
we're sort of an industrial engineering
department that's kind of pushing over
to the sociology side of things and what
it really is is the study of human
behavior on a collective level that's a
pretty broad scope but that's kind of
what it is it ranges from very micro
level studies of how people interact in
groups almost social psychology sort of
things to these more macro studies that
are very much more like macro sociology
or macro economics were you looking at
patterns and group behavior you know
across all the companies you know I'll
start companies in the Boston area I'll
start companies in
United States for a period of time and
seeing what patterns have you here you
see they're so kind of a wide range like
eclectic group draws on multiple types
of methods and covers a wide range of
stuff even in this space I'm a little
weird how I ended up in here and in
organization studies to begin with was
actually because I wanted to study
software development processes and
wasn't really satisfied with the options
I saw with in computer science so prior
to my PhD as i mentioned i did work a
couple times as professional developer
and what really struck me when I was out
there programming professionally what's
how really little we seem to know when I
was on the ground working with people
that are actually doing it day to day
about the software development process
I'd spent a lot of time in school
learning all those technical information
compilers programming languages you know
system architecture trying to get all
that information out there but then when
they actually send you out to go do work
you find out that like that's I mean
it's not the easy part but that's been
the part you got covered and there's
this whole component to being able to
actually create a product that works
really well and do it within a time you
know that's reasonable to meet schedules
that no one really ever covered at least
not at Stanford they just sort of not
only teach it either so like do it you
guys can figure out that part you know
we're going to teach you the really
tough technical stuff and when I was out
there working when I asked people sort
of like why are you doing what you do
there weren't really good answers people
sort of were just like well that's kind
of how it's done and they make
assertions about what was effective and
what wasn't really effective but there
didn't seem to be sort of a lot of data
behind it and there wasn't a lot of
research about there and so when I
started on my own this is a master
student looking around just to see what
people actually knew about these
processes I was kind of astonished to
find that a there wasn't very much in my
opinion and be what I could find really
seemed to ignore what to me was the most
critical part of the problem there's a
lot of looking at software development
processes sort of technical right let's
see metrics what are the
interdependencies it's happening here
and to me it was like well actually
what's really happening is it's actually
a social process it's a group process
it's about coordinating the efforts of
multiple people together and so when I
started really thinking about well where
would I study this organization studies
who studies group behaviors
organizations studies people do and that
sort
how I ended up in that arena so in terms
of that's how I got to organization
studies in terms of my specific research
interests but I'm interested in studying
is different forms of software
development work practices and so for me
in particular what I've been looking at
lately are agile methodologies so that
includes extreme programming which I'll
talk about today pair programming unit
testing open workspace is just different
ways in which people do software
development work theoretically might
purchase to think of software
development as a process of collective
knowledge sharing so it's something
where people know things each developer
on a team has some piece of the pie that
they know but in order for the entire
team as a whole to produce the product
they need to be able to share that
information effectively on a day-to-day
basis and my goal for my work is to have
three major three major applications I'd
like to think that I contribute to the
larger understanding of the software
development process I also like to think
that I provide developers and managers
with some concrete information about the
practices and methods that they're
considering so if you're making the
choice to adopt a practice or method or
particular tool even to have some
concept concept of what the consequences
might be of those adoptions and then
also to help inform the design of new
tools and practices that might improve
and support this process just had a
philosophical level sort of how your
work our approach differs from zoar what
people in what's classically known as
experimental software engineering have
done thinking of people like big Vasily
is studied
his whole factory for knowledge
knowledge factory so looking at
organizations and how they capture
information and other people who looked
at things like code inspections you know
I mean so there's there's been a sort of
a wealth of work around around studying
people in groups and software
development sometime just wanted to
understand sort of in the set of the
nets that have that setting where your
words um so when I read the stuff that I
read I and people aren't completely just
unaware that it's a group process right
like that's in the back of my mind but
the focus has always been sort of like
terms of what people how they work
together like I've seen a lot of studies
that are bake-offs for instance between
two methods right and the evaluations I
feel are sort of well I'll tell you what
my criticism of the whole field when I
started looking at it one the first one
was that I felt like they were sorted
out of touch right it was a little bit
like delayed right then your was stuff
that was happening on the ground it
seemed to be more reactive like you saw
what people were doing and then you know
would study but there's this time delay
between what that was happening and so
what I was kind of interested in doing
was going out there and being as close
to it as possible to see what what
people were immediately doing right away
to provide feedback as soon as possible
so like for instance XP for me was a big
interesting problem because I could see
people starting to really think about
these things and I wanted to go out and
be like well what are you actually doing
and how is that really affecting what
you're doing and for me the second part
was just more as a less that people
aren't necessarily cognizant of the
social but more that organizational
studies is this really rich field of
models of human behavior in a group
process and I thought like they've
studied this so much in a different
context there must be some applicability
right so it's not saying that like
everyone in computer science got it
wrong so much as that was necessarily
their focus but this group has been
studying it for like 50 to 100 years so
let's see what their models and their
theories can really be brought into this
particular application space about
so does that kind of help okay so I want
to talk a little bit about my current
projects and not so to give you some
background as to what I'm going to
present here so in terms of working
towards this sort of research goals that
that I explained in the previous slide
I've done a couple different projects
I've been involved in several fields
phase of development teams I actually
think at this point I've done for with
four different teams looking at
different aspects of it knowledge
sharing behaviors is what I'll be
talking about today acid it'd some other
work earlier on interruption behaviors
also on XP and pair programming or sorry
XP and waterfall teams and I've also
kind of got some other stuff coming out
that's on the social technical dynamics
of preparing specifically so that's
comparing behaviors on different pair
programming teams talk about what kind
of factors in that company on those two
teams affect how people work together in
pair probing environments and then some
work that's actually partially sponsored
by MSR is doing both the field and an
experimental comparison of pair program
or performance and some of the stuff
that we're thinking about looking at
there are sort of decision making an
information fidelity within these pairs
so that's kind of what's on the plate
what I'm going to talk about today is
the ethnographic work and this is the
this is my dissertation work so that's
the heart of it it's a comparative
ethnographic study of knowledge sharing
behaviors on to software development
teams one in which uses extreme
programming and one of which uses the
waterfall method so I don't know how
familiar people are with XP so I wanted
to give a little bit of background in
case they weren't i give this you know
different talks to different audiences
and you can never quite tell so what X
fuse is this sort of new software
development in pathology that's come out
in the late 90s Kent backwards sort of
the definitive book on it in two
thousand I mean it uses some really
radical software development practices
I've alluded to some of them programming
work in pairs working in a large urban
work spaces are so the two that I've
been focusing on in the past couple
years but they do a whole bunch of other
stuff i'm going to explain a little bit
more about the other practices but i
don't want to give you the full spectrum
because that's talk about that for a
full 60 minutes
and the other team used what I call here
the waterfall process but is not really
the true sort of waterfall passes for a
more the typical setup that you would
see if you hadn't picked a random
company what you're most likely to see
that set of practices in what size of
software systems are you focusing are
you focusing on the development say
100,000 line software system or a
million line or 10 million line software
system um they're mid-sized I don't
actually I had the line count somewhere
I don't remember exactly what that is
it's not for instance the size of you
know windows here but this is going to
its network management software and so
it includes sort of like trying to think
of what I could say without giving away
the company IP servers that sort of
thing like so substantial code pretty
complicated code and it has to work for
a whole bunch of different situations
but the question is are you developing
software that has to meet a standard or
are you developing software that is
innovative and there is no standard that
it has to adhere to um they have to deal
with the network protocols right so they
do have to work with the standards body
and know quite a lot about that
information but in terms of the
functionality inside there the different
products that they have they have some
freedom to you know try to come up with
new features that might be interesting
to the to their customer base does that
kind of give you a sense of where where
they are in that space so they're not
sort of like the cutting edge let's be
crazy you know let's come up with Gmail
and you're you know in your coffee cup
that you can check while you runs for a
space they're more part of an
established system but they have a
little bit of freedom so not just
totally writing
so to talk a little bit about this study
what this particular study aims look at
three basic questions so first of all
what I wanted to do is just get a basic
descriptive sense of where and when
developers seek information in the
course of work there's been a couple
studies in that space but i thought well
i'm doing this ethnographic study here's
a really good opportunity to be like
okay what do they actually turn to when
they're working what sources do they go
to where are they looking what kind of
questions they're asking second as I
started really learning about extreme
programming I started to get really
curious about how XP practices
facilitate or impede knowledge sharing
among the teams mostly this came out of
a lot of conversations with people who
are really into XP XP proponents and
they give a lot of justifications for
why you should use XP or why a
particular practice works well together
and I really wanted to say well can you
know can you back up that claim if I go
into you know three XP teams will I see
that and so I've started here with one
to say okay well what can we link the
practices that that are they're doing to
actual knowledge sharing behaviors and
what happens when we try to take a look
at that and then finally how can an
understanding of knowledge sharing
practices among developers help inform
the design of work tools and management
strategies up these three questions what
I'm going to talk about today are sort
of the findings that are a bit most
development to the second question so
the effective XP practices are knowledge
sharing behaviors although I'll touch a
little bit about question 3 as I go
through each of the findings there but
before I get to that let me tell you a
little bit about the two teams in
question so I conducted observations at
two product teams and a mid-sized
software development company in Silicon
Valley so by midsize it was a little bit
bigger than what you typically consider
a start-up it's about 100 people had
been going for a couple years probably
think it's been around for about five to
six years when I was there I spent a
total of ten months in the field with
the two teams I did a three-month pilot
study with the XP team initially just
after they were formed actually about a
month after they came together and then
seven months with the other two teams
and it's a four months with the
waterfall team and then I went back to
the XP team a little bit later in there
a development cycle both these teams
worked on pretty closely related
software so like I said network
management software designed primarily
for network administrator's one teams
project this is the XP team was written
primarily in Java the other teams
project was primarily in Python they see
these little Java as well I mean in
order to ensure that the behavior I
observed on these teams wasn't
particular to a particular phase in
their development cycle I stuck with
both teams through one cycle planning
design implementation and product
release although not necessarily in that
order because of time constraints so to
talk about the actual practices that
these teams use XP has between 12 to 14
like official practices depending on who
you talk to the practices cover all
different parts of the software
development process ranging from you
know how you should do project planning
to how long your work Rick should
ideally be so I won't address all of
them but just enough to give you a
flavor on what I think is important to
understand how work on this particular
team unfolds in accordance to the XP
specifications project on this team was
done in short two to three-week
iterations right so the beginning of
each iteration they would get a list of
features that they wanted to implement
go through implementation and
theoretically at the end of the two-week
implementation it was as if they'd
completed a release that was ready to
your customer even if there wasn't an
actual customer who's waiting for it
whenever possible of each of the
features that they picked for that
iteration were then broken down into one
or two day tasks that they then would
put in a big queue and the developers
would come and pull them off as they
completed task whenever possible the
work on this team was done in pairs so
that means to developers would work side
by side on a single shared machine had
two monitors two keyboards but only one
and two mice but one machine and only
one person could control the mouse or
the keyboard at a particular time and
the pair's would do is very structured
way of working on their task they would
first sit down to write test routines
for the functionality they hope to
implement they would then design and
implement the functionality and then the
idea was that when all your tests that
you'd initially written pass then you
were done with that task and you could
check in and this cycle is pretty short
they tried to check in as quickly as
often as possible so they would be
checking in multiple times a day and the
developers would switch pairs on a daily
basis so you'd work with one person on
Monday and even if your task took longer
than monday which
judge to tuesday or wednesday the next
day we were working with a different
partner the idea behind that was to help
distribute the knowledge of that
particular task across people on the
team so and the team was also located in
a large open space which I'll give you a
picture right here it's essentially an
image of the XP team that I studied so
you can kind of get a sense of the size
of the space it wasn't a really huge
group but you what you see here is any
one two three four but six different
workstations and two sets of pairs
working at that space some point boards
along the side where they have written
stuff on there they have some cardboards
in that but they never use that like it
didn't change the into our four months I
was there and so they have good visual
and aural access to each other you can
see kind of how close they are yeah all
season what was this team with XP well
the team itself was brand new but the
people on the team it got to about 10
people at one point and the initial
three have had no prior XP experience
before joining this team but everyone
else had so they it's not like they were
kind of flying Blatt and they kind of
knew what the deal was and they had
worked with XP it actually multiple
different companies developers and
testers uh yeah actually what you can't
see is there's some three docs they have
on the side of the room over here and
they put their project manager here they
put it there tester here the two of them
at they hired another one in the course
of the observations and they had like a
marketing kind of guy over there and
initially the test version like that
because they weren't part of the XP team
originally the part of the rest of the
company but over time like people just
ended up relocating all their stuff
inside the cute because they were inside
this bullpen because they were working
so closely with them so I didn't
explicitly follow them but a lot of what
I watched when the developers was
interacting with those people because
they're right on site so or any other
questions about the XP team I guess
before I go on yeah how divers were the
teens either gender was not very hey one
of the testers was a women um both teams
and one developer was female
a waterfall pain yeah in academia
there's a lot of interest in using
extreme programming in the introductory
course and there's a big discussion of
should the team's be the same gender or
mix genders yes Collins with this I was
interested in that as well but then when
you got to actually fine Tunes it's like
well there's one woman like how much can
you generalize from her yeah question
any of the tools that the XP team used
has been designed from the ground out to
be what tool for a bio extreme on
programming mm yes and no they had a
build system that they wrote themselves
specifically for that project and for
their team they used the actual physical
cardboard for a while but their project
manager didn't like it so they actually
bought a pre design it's called version
1 it's a typical like it's written for
to support XP task management it's a
web-based application they use that so
it wasn't customized to their team that
was off the shelf actually the waterfall
team had more specific software like
they had built a lot of the system's
themselves so this is the waterfall team
again they had the typical software
development practices not sort of
strictly waterfall they have much longer
iterations ranging from one to two
months they did do the linear task
sequence at the beginning of an
iteration you would get a list of
features the whole group would generate
a list of features based on the customer
feedback and then the they would split
those features among the developers on
the team trying to match what so your
previous expertise was so if you're like
been working on databases for a year you
kind of got the database features and
each developer would then write up a
pretty long design document outlining
what they intended to do to implement
that feature that we get sent to the
entire group and they'd have a big
meeting where everyone would discuss it
you kind of let your design on the board
and people would give critiques you'd
integrate that into your design document
and when everyone approved you would
implement it and then test it in the
implementation phase the developers
would primarily work individually they
did consult each other they'd wander
over to people's cubes ask questions via
Lily which I'll talk about a second but
primarily you worked independently you
had a lot of latitude over your work
process so you saw a little bit more
variation in terms of specific practices
just to give one example like in terms
of the times that people actually came
to work most people on the team kind of
worked the typical 10 to seven like the
Silicon Valley nine to five you will
work day but some people would stay
overnight just kind of like they just
decide like well you know I'm kind of
gotten in a groove it's like nine
o'clock i'm just going to stay till like
six a.m. and then take all friday off
and they would just do that one guy
actually kept like Australian time
because his significant other was in
Australia so he just like wouldn't come
in until morning in Australia and they
need to stay a night nice try yeah
actually the other developers hated that
but you did it anyway and they were they
were relatively cool with it they had
individual machines and their individual
cubes so that everyone had a cubicle
they tried to put people kind of close
to each other you couldn't really see
what other people were doing around you
but you could easily easily hear what
was going on around you and the team
members on this team regularly worked
from home they had two members that were
remote one was in Chicago one was in
Finland actually both he was part time
and what they used was Lily which is a
computer mediated communication tool
it's sort of a big chat room with
different lies that you can subscribe to
so your team would have a line and so
whenever you send a message that
everyone in the team would get that to
keep in touch and they really they use
the lil wat like they would be there on
weekends at night one told me that
anytime I'm in front of a computer and
awake I'm on Lily sister what were the
reporting structures for those constant
two teams or um they both had one
manager in charge of them does that make
sense they are reportedly no they each
had their own manager and so similar
very little establish hierarchy it's not
like one had you know three sub managers
in charge of everyone did you observe
the interactions between the chains
um I tried the waterfall team manager is
the remote guy he I did observe him when
he came on site he would visit regularly
because he was remote on site but um
they kind of ended up mostly self
managing themselves and I'd say the XP
team was pretty much the same way like
the managers on both teams were so busy
kind of interfacing with either upper
management or actually the customers
they needed to talk to that they weren't
really there a day to day to like handle
like what are we going to do today yeah
the eater taint have a quality plan in
terms of how to like a sasquatch and
make improvements like like a tqm style
thing well all of you in the sense that
the object of the game is customer
satisfaction not really like the XP team
talked about it a lot but then actually
didn't go out and find customers and the
other team kept in touch with their
customers but had no real specific way
had no metric for for how we're going to
assess whether they're happy or not it's
I mean despite the fact that it was
established it was still sort of in
start-up mode like the especially among
the management had low bandwidth I mean
they were so busy just dealing with
people that their method was sort of
like if the customer isn't yelling at us
they must be happy um that was sort of
their um they both had automated build
systems the XP one was continuous
throughout the day the waterfall one ran
every night it was a totally different
system they had built them both custom
for the two teams but the big difference
I say would be that the waterfall teams
system was heavily reliant on email
notification so anytime someone checked
in it would send email to the entire
group and this is something they
actually read very carefully they
actually very good sense of any time
someone made a change what that change
was worse is the XP team those they
didn't have that going on so they they
actually just sort of everyone threw in
check-ins and they had an automated
built that were just run and they'd see
what other things that failed hmm how
much of the different team behaviors
that you observed you have triggered to
the difference between the processes the
development processes explained
wonderful and how much you attribute to
the different differences in the teens
with a colocation facility
um I'll in 20 minutes see if you saw
that question okay okay so
methodological what I did I visited each
team weekly during their session i SAT
there for three to five hours with them
the five it that includes like lunches
and you know coffee breaks and stuff
like that I would sit behind the
developer or the pair of developers as I
work and I took pretty extensive notes
of the actions in the context of their
action so whatever they were doing that
day why what other stuff is going on in
their environment to cause them to do
that to kind of help I use audio
recording at all times in order to
capture both dialogue and sort of
ambient noises that was actually really
helpful what i would do is then
transcribe this audio and integrate it
with my notes you get a pretty detailed
observation of each transcript or
transcript of each observation these
would run to almost like 40 pages each
in terms of getting down pretty granular
to what they're doing in any given time
I would then reread and read to search
for larger themes that I saw were
happening and then basically seems I
would develop our criteria for
identifying and categorizing recurring
behaviors that were in the data that
should be related to my themes but
weren't directly dependent on them to
try to verify that this was in fact
happening in a way that's more than just
I sit there and I see it a lot but also
that I can support it with actual
behaviors hmm you do anything to protect
against the Hawthorne effect that your
observations we're going to affect the
team behavior um it's sort of a limited
enough that you can do when you're going
in to go sit behind them I mean they're
very cognizant of what they're being
observed I tried to observe every person
two or three times to try it it so the
very first observation I would always
notice that people would be a little bit
cagey r justifying what they're doing in
terms of of trying to to justify and
provide explanations for everything that
were sort of like what you would expect
like the group norm right like people
would be like I'm writing this because
every good developer should write
documentation right and I'm like I'd
come back two more times and they never
write any more documentation or often
for instance one guy was always on Lily
whenever I wasn't observing anyone else
like they have their windows up so I can
see all the the chats that are going to
this line and like when I wasn't
observing him he was like constantly
sending
statistically replied the first time I
observed in like he didn't send a
message all day hey hey so yeah so I
would try to go I went to everyone
multiple times in order to make sure
that that in any difference since their
first day's behavior was like really too
crazy i would throw it out i wouldn't
actually even consider it it'd just be
like well that was the warm-up for
observations yeah how many visits total
did you have it's hard to remember I
think I have 18 for one team and then
around 15 for the other but that doesn't
include the pilot data and some on each
team that XP they both buried the XP
team range between seven and ten people
and the waterfall team think was between
six and eight so I didn't get a chance
to observe everyone like for instance
the Australian time guy just never
managed to get that one he wasn't you
didn't respond to email and so I never
got to talk to him but I tried to get
everyone there multiple times again to
get back to do what their standard
practice was and not just what they
thought they should be doing one being
observed the XP team actually I didn't
do that as much because it was really
easy they were actually really they're
used to being in this environment where
all as people watching them right like
because they're in that space so they
were very capable of ignoring me like I
was like ignore me and they pretty much
did you know Tyra said I kind of felt
that that was not not such a problem yes
did you still sit behind
yeah I still stuck with a particular
pair I tried a couple different things
during the pilots and it just seemed
ports work better where you're like okay
I'm gonna focus on this one person and
go with it in terms of coding for
behaviors to back up sort of themes what
I do is I went and looked at knowledge
sharing behavior so I thought okay well
what I'm interested is not sharing what
can I see that they're tangibly doing
that I can look for and then kind of
explore how it relates to the practices
they're doing and so I kind of broke
knowledge-sharing down into two
components right I thought okay to
people they need to exchange knowledge
there's two ways that it can happen I
can either go find you because I know
that you have or think that you have
some information that I need so i can go
seek knowledge or oftentimes people will
just tell you stuff right like you won't
have asked but will come up to you and
be like hey i think it this might be
relevant to you or just kind of you know
give you information and so that's
knowledge offering so these are the two
events that i categorize for i basically
looked for very explicit acts so it had
to be something that was marked by an
explicit question from one person to
another and that's i can talk a little
bit more in detail about that when i get
to how i use these I mean I also looked
at knowledge externalization which is
just my fancy word for whenever they
wrote stuff down this is really
interested in what they were trying to
record I'm I also actually looked it
whenever they looked at recorded
knowledge but that I'm not going to talk
about that today and then just to give
you an idea of how many events they were
going on on each team on the XP team i
saw a total of eight hundred and forty
events across these two categories 543
not seeking 214 knowledge offering 83
knowledge externalization on the
waterfall team 245 events 109 knowledge
seeking 69 offering in 67
externalization hmm so Jen did you get a
sense of how much time did they actually
spend programming versus no programming
activities that was on my goal but I
haven't actually done the actual time
breakdown of that in terms of
calculating I have some numbers that
talk to about like what phase of the
barium activity they're sort of in but
they're in their very rough a sense but
their default activity it's hard to
break it out because they'll turn and
then they'll come back and so it's like
what you end up being like okay well for
30 seconds I they stopped and their back
or do you count that as part of
the programming activity which is why I
haven't gone and refined that further by
default though I think most of the time
they're pretty much programming I mean
do you mean programming in terms of
their actually generating code or doing
related things to cogeneration like we
did this study he discovered people's
better make it order a full supporter of
their time in a 40-hour week writing a
program the rest of it was due to other
activities make spurious is contesting
for instance does that count as
programming or chunka that was being in
meetings in military oh yeah no these
guys had one meeting every morning that
was kind of it so of their time that
that not so much on the SB side they're
talking all the time to each other and
other people so it's like hard to say
when did they stop and when were they
programming with really not programming
on the waterfall time they mostly worked
alone and the time when they deviated
from that was very specific they didn't
spend a lot of time having meetings with
each other and they didn't have a lot of
time going over and talk to each other i
would say mostly actually if they
deviated from it they were goofing off
so i mean like i SAT behind people while
they were watching like i want to star
trek videos behind people and stuff like
that but it wasn't taken up by meeting
activi okay so to kind of preview what I
found going to watch a couple page I'm
going to talk about today are two
principal themes that I saw going on in
the two teams on the first team that
emerged was the XP practices seems to
make technical design and status
knowledge much more transparent among
the team members and the water fault
practices did for the waterfall team
members so for each of these findings
when we do is present some qualitative
data drawing on some vignettes and very
illustrative events that happened to
kind of illustrate how the practices
might lead to this transparency for this
one and then what I'll try to do is look
at how this transparency is also
reflected in the pattern of knowledge
sharing behaviors on the two teams I'm
for this one and specifically I'm going
to look at the pattern of knowledge
offering incidents and knowledge sharing
knowledge seeking incidences and the
second beam that I'm going to talk about
today is that all the knowledge may be
much more prevalent on this few teams on
the XP team the XP model of knowledge
distribution also appears to be more
lossy
than the waterfall model of knowledge
distribution which is to say that that
although they know at any given point of
time what's going on on their team they
don't retain that information very well
from say week to week the lasting nature
this knowledge again I was going to say
that it's reflected in the content of
what they're recording on these two
teams which is not the perfect measure
but it's sort of a small window into to
what what's going on there okay so XP
has got a lot of practices so I'm just
going to talk about the two biggest
contributors to knowledge transparency
here pair programming and open workspace
so pair programming was a rich source of
knowledge transparency on the XP team
paired work provides a rich situated
exposure into the technology the
technical and design knowledge that
other people possess in this example is
a pretty typical exchange between two
programmers here Andy and Brian there
what they're going to do is they're
constructing a chain of logic to explain
why change that they've made to the code
does not fix its failing test and so
that's what they're doing at the very
beginning they've made a change they're
running it and they say okay well it
still fails why is that what you can see
through this dialog is that knowledge is
made visible across pair partners as
each programmer articulates their
thoughts about the current task so one
guys kind of giving their hypothesis and
confirming the other person's assessment
or altering it this practice not only
facilitates the sharing of factual
technical information there's kind of an
example that here at the very bottom
where Andy starts looking for a place to
put the test he doesn't explicitly ask
but brian says no actually there's a
better place for that we should do that
in the person persistence test case
instead but on a more fundamental level
what it's really making visible is the
process of reasoning inherent in code
design which if you think about it in
more traditional programming
environments is usually obscured really
you don't get to see that in fact but
usually see is sort of the end result
the the finished code and then you have
to sort of guess it why they've made the
decisions they did there and hear their
kind of seeing the whole process
institue they get to see for instance
what aspects of the problem becomes
salient when you're actually approaching
you know write a function that will do
this or add this functionality program
and how people renegotiate Andrey
conceptualize problem constraints in
order to construct a working solution
stuff that again is just simply not
really available
the waterfall cider has to be gleaned
post-hoc in addition to pairing the
practice of working in a shared open
workspace serve to not only make the
status of the people around them more
visible across the team but facilitated
knowledge sharing across team members as
knowledgeable developers could provide
information to those around them even
when not directly address so here in
this example what's going to happen is
they're in the space they have the build
monitor on one side of the room and in
this case one of the builds failed to
the monitors flashing red to indicate
that there's something wrong and Carl's
walking across or sorry Darren's walking
across the room and he sees bill mater
he's going to stop turn towards it start
walking towards it and reach for the
mouse that kind of like lets you bring
up the more specific display about what
tests are failing Carl's sitting on the
side of the room he's already been
working on this problem sees Darren
working says hey I knew what that
problem is right differences yet he says
I'm going to go over start it it's a
strange timeout thing I don't really
know why it's happening on solaris but
it does i'm working on it you know
here's what's going to happen so here
again Darren never asked anyone he never
asked Carl what was going on with the
build Carl just sees what he's doing
knows what information he's trying to
get him for that reasonably well and is
able to provide a solution for for pride
information that he wants so developers
can actually glean a pretty impressive
amount of information from these
channels I had a pretty long manana a
knish so I'm just going to tell you what
happened because it takes two slides
during which the pair of developers in
this environment we're working on this
bug it got really frustrated it was
taped they've been working on it all day
turned out actually to be a change
unrelated to their code which is why
they're having so much trouble fixing it
but in the middle of it they got so
frustrated that one of them just kind of
like got up and walked out of the room
because he was so pissed off he's like
oh I can't do what anymore and you
stomped out of the room the other guy
was like what do I do now you know I'm
working by myself and what you saw was
that the people working around them kind
of like proactively just came in and
started taking over the task when they
saw that this pair would become
unfunctional anymore right like
literally the people next time just
moved in and instantly started being
like okay let's look at this file run
this test let's see we're going to
happen there was no sort of period of
what are you doing what's the problem
what have you done already they were
able to glean that just from being
around them and she's really pretty cool
um oh I put the slides in there well no
well the waterfall team
has a very different pattern of behavior
the channels again for design and
technical knowledge are simply
unavailable their status information is
available but in sort of this
temporarily limited fashion so what they
kind of do is they do periodic broadcast
from other team members announcing
progress that's a very common behavior
on this team so as you see here at the
top example Jack's looking over
something he gets a message from Kate
who's just telling him that he's fixed a
compiler bug on one of their but one of
the bugs on one of the builds that's
causing it to not compile and and also
through the automated notifications that
their build system sends out that people
pay close attention to because that's
one of the limited ways that they can
get that information both of these
mechanisms are however fundamentally
voluntarily if I don't check in my code
into the CBS sheriff for like two weeks
you don't really know and if I'm not
telling you what's going on you don't
know what I'm doing developers like to
be seen as competent this is true on
both teams they don't like to kind of
like top people like while I was writing
this and I hit seven bugs and I really
don't know what to do they prefer
instead to actually whenever they run
into issues like that they usually try
to fix it themselves before they wanted
to tell people to try to be like oh I'm
all over it I'm in this bottom example
what's happening is a developer named
Leigh is receiving these pretty frantic
messages from the rest of the group over
Lily because he's checked in code that
doesn't have a set of changes that he's
actually promised to make and they need
those changes before they can release
the code to the customer who's actually
just waiting for the product this was a
deployed product so they're doing
real-time updates out there but leg
who's been delayed by some unexpected
bugs in the code is just not responding
to queries like I don't know why but
people are coming into the asking him
questions and he's just kind of like no
I'm on it it'll be fine when they're
like when you're going to check-in he
keeps going soon and then same with
these messages that are coming in a
Roselli he kind of reads them and sort
of like ignores them but what you see
here is that because he's unwilling to
give out this information the team
around was pretty limited in what they
can learn about the situation by
contrast if you think about that
vignette that I talked about on the XP
team even those those developers also
did not want to give that information
that indicated that they were in trouble
they couldn't really hide it like
everyone on the team around them do it
and could see exactly kind of what their
problem
so the difference is in knowledge
transparency that are engendered by
these work practices also reflected in
the aggregate pattern of knowledge
sharing behaviors on the two teams so
remind you what we're looking at here is
all the times in the data when a
programmer asked another programmer for
information what type of program
information did they ask for this is
sort of oh the colors really didn't come
out very well the projector but what I
did was pretty rough coding I didn't
splice in to say which model are you
asking questions about I could but
haven't done that yet it's mostly high
level is it technical information is a
coordination information is it status
information errs at miscellaneous
information yeah so coordination
information is when you're splitting up
division of labor between two people so
you're saying I'm going to do this are
you going to do that status is sort of
what's the progress on that so far
technical was anything related why how
does this work you know why is this code
working this way what is the protocol
for this and miscellaneous is anything
else ranging from things like how's your
dog you know that kind of information
over there so here we have the
distribution of question content on the
two teams and as you can see the XP
knowledge seeking events are
predominantly technical in nature
seventy-seven percent and the largest
category of the waddle far side is also
technical queries about fifty percent of
all the seeking incidences that I
observes the most telling difference
between these two lies in the secondary
categories developers on both teams seek
out coordination information fifteen
percent of time on the XP team
twenty-five percent on the waterfall
time but the waterfall developers
inquire about status to a much much
higher degree seventeen percent of their
queries involved asking other people
what their statuses there's only four
percent of that happens on the XP in row
Caesar conversational turn saying oh
what are you doing right now as opposed
to the waterfall side were there really
segment what's going on please tell me
what was happening there so this
reflects the ready availability of
status information on the XP side and
the need to offset the opacity of status
information on the waterfall side
through explicit questions about status
hmm
so you look at these as pie cards as
percentage of yeah and it's not the
right thing is that's all right way to
be comparing you know seven percent of
fifteen percent or or is it really
absolute numbers if you want number per
unit time number for you to time Ike I
could do that um what would that ad
doing number free anytime so assume the
number people is the same and then the
amount of time is the same control for
that if XP people are if you still have
okay XP people are asking nothing more
about technical last ransom and then
waterfall people absolute numbers and it
appears that they are by overwhelming
majority does that mean that that that
could mean do you think one is it
there's worth more accessibility so they
ask those questions and the other thing
has been there's a whole lot less
information so they need okay I got it
so you're saying the numbers don't
really yeah I so to compare I normalized
the numbers on the two right so it's
adjusted for the amount of time that I
saw the two teams so that's that's a
normalized number at the XP side gets a
normalized but it turns out i saw them
for a few hours less observations with
them but they actually had still raw
numbers more events on the XP side a lot
of this is pair programmers between each
other and so when I initially did this
analysis I actually did only across
pairs and i think i might have the slide
I'm not sure to look at well
accessibility right the person next she
was so accessible in the course of
working together you would by default
ask them questions right so is that
really valid and I kind of went back and
forth and it turns out whenever i
present it without the pair's people say
what do the pair's do so for this one I
tried to put it all together and I if
you look like what what do you do it out
that there's so maybe I'll just have to
show both but I do have the numbers in
the proportion the number of technical
queries decreases a little I think goes
about here on the x
side but the relative proportion stays
the same across people so this is if you
think of it in terms of one you have to
go outside of the people you're most
accessible to write you still see that
same pattern yeah how many of the
questions that were going between the
people in the parents were really just
instances of distributed cognition where
they were just using the other as a
crutch as opposed to actually really ask
you a real question so this isn't
reflect every question that was asked
but I actually use the metric a bit
similar to what you guys did for the
information needs which is just the
their chunked into if you ask question
that starts and knowledge-sharing
incident right and then there's some
judgment involved in seeing when do you
actually switch the new task and
actually do on your daddy Cory's I'm to
try to help make that determination to
say okay well when am i seeing a totally
new instance so like if you're in a
meeting and i'll send you say wait you
know i want to talk about this can i ask
a few questions about that that's new
right that would be a separate one but i
don't code every single question so if
you're talking to each other in the
course of banter right then then that's
not counted as for that would just be
say one who watch over in a few and I
try to be a little conservative actually
about it just to make sure I didn't get
the noise in there so I only picked him
if they were very clear examples of a
knowledge seeking instantly I don't know
this and I need that information yeah oh
you are did you look at sort of learning
over time I'm thinking that in the XP
one way to characterize XP is you could
think of it as an apprenticeship model
that no matter how people are paired up
there's going to be one person has some
expertise I mean it can go both ways
it's not necessarily no one's superior
to the other you know are the teacher
and the others the student and sort of
overtime you know the hope is with
something like XP are the hypothesis is
that everybody becomes more expert in
all parts of the system whereas
waterfall you tend to your expertise
tends to be more compartmentalized and
so I just wonder sort of is there a way
to look at learning like like having a
test you know at the beginning in the
end
so there's knowledge but then there's
sort of what do what do people so I
didn't do that explicitly here it is one
of the questions that I was really
interested in but methodologically I was
like I'm biting off a big piece already
so you know next study um what I did
dated sort of addresses that is I looked
at not it uses these observations but
also a second XP team to see what the
dynamics were on the two and the one
that we found that was really
interesting is on that team they had a
project structure that had a hardware
component and a software component to it
like code that worked really closely
with the hardware product that they were
making in them the software that a lot
of people to control it but the team was
responsible parties but you saw a clear
divide in terms of the developers on
that team who were really the hardware
gurus and the developers 19 that were
soft workers and when you paired across
that expertise level like when you have
one person who was really strong in one
versus someone who's really weekend the
other it was actually what I might call
dysfunctional pair behavior would happen
which is that the expert just started
taking over the entire task and the
second person wasn't really contributing
much to it at all so that sort of not
precisely your question but sort of what
I've kind of found in different other
areas any some any other question yeah
what was the knowledge sharing behavior
vary in time for the life of the project
um I didn't look at that yet I could I
have that data but I have not I've run a
lot of other numbers now so that's nice
Melissa the other problem that I was
thinking about doing the learning one it
was really tough to get like the pair's
picked themselves ad hoc every morning
so it was really tough to come in and be
like no I want to see you and you work
together because I know last week you
worked on this and I want to see whether
you know because I know you're not that
expert on areas so that it this wasn't
best suited to answer that yet which is
the following up on clubs question
enough there are studies indicated that
the difference in productivity between
programmers can be as much as a factor
of 50 to 1 mm what happens when you have
who pair that one is just so much more
experienced and productive than the
other is that all so dysfunctional
yeah what happens well it was more
related to how much they knew about the
the topic the task at hand so like if
you had someone who was really basically
what it is is that if you have a non
dysfunctional pair at least in the all
the observations that I've seen they
kind of come up to this level of
productivity XP guys are really focused
they're pretty much working all the time
like I couldn't tell you whether they're
producing quality hood for the time they
are because I couldn't get the code from
the two teams that I looked at but in
terms of actual just focused work on the
programming task they're doing that for
the entire eight-hour day whenever you
have a pair the dysfunction happens when
that happens is when one guy knows so
much more that the other guys feels like
they're slowing the whole pare down too
much if they try to ask questions to
come up to speed but if they know enough
to ask informed questions right they
don't have to be equal they just have to
be kind of like enough in the space that
you're not saying like oh we explain to
me what this is a very basic level then
they actually end up contributing and
functioning as a pretty you know
reasonably high end up looking sort of
like as a normal pair on the waterfall
team you can see huge differences sort
of what is more documented in indy
studies where you have some people that
are focused their productive they come
to work the full three hours that I
observe them they were writing code the
whole time they were very productive
they would get stuck periodically think
about it and then immediately move and
then you had these guys that were
literally like every 15 minutes we're
doing something else right like they
were like watching videos they were
talking about stuff talking to me you're
trying to talk to other people and so
that's kind of what I noticed in terms
of productivity I did not assess the
quality of what they were writing so I
didn't say like maybe in the 15 minutes
that they did work they were brilliant
stuff you know where's the other guys
turning out crap for three hours
like the name objective metrics like
number of finished lines of code
produced per hour in the two different
projects no I didn't get into their CVS
share I really want I really tried to be
able to run some numerical analysis on
what code was being entered the most i
could get was through interviews people
would tell me I had talked to a couple
of the managers that kind of saw both
teams and they would say this team is
phenomenally more productive in terms of
lines of code generated than that team
like if you just look at the amount
that's being added to the code base
every week that was the best I could do
for this one and I thought well I have
so much other data let me look at those
phenomena and try to maybe design a
different study that would let me in
assess you know maybe even more
experimental because again it's also
hard to compare when you have two
different projects to certain extent
right about what's going on so I tried
to look at behaviors that I could say
you know the interdependence across
these two teams is reasonably similar or
you know the types of project knowledge
they have to need the is reasonably
similar so I can make these more
high-level comparisons yeah you can
still look in the delivery system the
number of lines of code that went out in
the first version and then look at the
number of programmers how much
programming effort went into the each
yeah you see if there were any
significant differences in terms of
productivity of the two different
methodologies I definitely could do that
is a lot harder on the waterfall side
because I guess that they've worked so
sporadically but it's hard to say what
were your number of programming hours
like the guy would be like well I was on
Willy all night I answered like 10
questions from support between like
midnight and 4am you know and then on
the weekend I did like a little work
he's like in my mind that counts as work
but it's definitely something I could
look into doing because I do have the
the data for that if I could go back and
at least get the lines of code just
destroyed worried about the amount that
the water hole spends on status mmhmm
yeah I mean they're just it's
information that they need and they have
to get it by asking people so and
curiosity was Lily usually how they did
status information um a bit both as it
got more urgent they would start showing
up in person um but yeah
how's your tongue Oh in the graphs here
are they multiply but as a numbers
multiplied by the time of each
interactive yeah so this is time that
you're oh no no it's it's not time it's
actually a number of events so I don't I
don't look at how long the events go for
I wanted to but it's like I mean 543
ended up being so high that I couldn't
really stop and get time for each one
but I mean I don't even remember my
interruption study that actually did get
time for those because I had 242 I think
and that was manageable but these the
numbers were so high that I was like I'd
like to graduate this year okay um so
that was seeking behavior the difference
is also perhaps more dramatically
visible if we look at the information
that developers are voluntarily telling
each other so here are all the knowledge
of volunteering events sorted by
relevance to the target so if I'm
telling you something right relevance to
whatever you're currently doing if I'm
if what I'm telling you solves the
immediate problem that you're working on
or that you're facing then I considered
this knowledge to be timely so that's
what the timely category means so for
instance in that open workspace example
where Darren's actually going and
looking to see why the bill fails Carl
tells him that maybe not exactly what
built bells but that he's on it and that
you know rough explanation of what he
knows about that that would be really
timely knowledge if it's relevant to
your task so general related to what
you're working on but not immediately
relevant to the problem at hand I
considered to be task relevant knowledge
if it's relevant to the larger project
you're working on but not your specific
task or your immediate problem then it's
considered project relevant knowledge
and then there's some of it that's just
totally random knowledge yeah so the
difference in the relevance of the
knowledge offered on the two teams is
striking 71 percent of the knowledge
offered between the developers on the XP
team is timely in nature so that's not
as directly relevant to the problem
faced by the person to whom the
knowledge is offered another twelve
percent of that is task relevant
knowledge another ten percent is project
development knowledge on the waterfall
side however only seventeen percent of
the nod offering incidences are timely
knowledge are timely knowledge and
offered instance instead 32 and 34
percent of them are task-relevant and
project relevant respectively
yeah XP sides that include the offering
between the partners mm-hmm and again
same thing when I reduce out the when I
take out the pair's the proportion stays
the same even though it just lessens the
timeliness lessons but it's still
extremely timely across Paris the
absolute numbers if I was in terms of
their still higher yeah yeah they're
still higher they're still higher than I
don't remember that magnitude if I think
I factor of three if you take that out
stood still much much higher yeah enough
that I wasn't like this is you know
clearly a pair of thing enough that it's
pretty clear I could put up the slide
with that and you'd probably say like
wow that's still pretty big different
yeah so only the categorization you had
on the previous slide this one I'm a
little bit more worried about external
validity or your name of your
categorization yeah so did you do
anything to try to probe whether whether
they would have categorized the same way
that you did well the way I gonna do it
was if it's the person that I'm watching
like if that solves their problem they
move on right to a different problem
than I can clearly consider that timely
and again I tried to be really
conservative about that the one thing I
couldn't really tell you is like maybe
they're blasting information that's
relevant but like kind of crappy right
like that could bite you later on and I
in many of the cases I I tried to do
that initially but I just didn't know
enough about kind of the deep internals
of their project to be able to assess
that necessarily often they wouldn't
even know like it could just be bad
information and it wouldn't come out for
a couple days right so I stuck with the
relevant stuff and what happened it was
fantastic project probably that was a
little bit easier because they actually
every morning I'd say what's your task
right and so they tell me what that was
it was easy for me to say like okay well
this is clearly related to what you're
doing versus not related to what you're
working on today
any other questions about this um so
let's see why because XP practices make
knowledge more transparent the
developers on the XP team are able to
regularly direct immediately revolt
relevant knowledge their peers to
precisely answer the questions that
they're being faced by their teammates
and like I said before these are very
specific I picked the I mean I only went
with what was a very clear example of
knowledge being yet like I wouldn't
consider it timely knowledge it wasn't
like usually it's like for instance I
don't know where the log files are on
this prop in this part of Patrick or
you'll see someone just searching and
saying things like oh it's a locked file
over here and someone will come in and
say the log files are actually in this
directory and will actually sit down at
the computer and show them it's stuff
like that so pretty clear glad it's not
like a vague those are the types of
questions that are being answered on the
waterfall teams to developers also try
to offer nod so it's not that one team
is more helpful than the other rate
they're both trying to help each other
on a regular basis but they lack the
same context as the XP developers and
instead they're directing their
knowledge based on what they know of the
developers current task or the project
or sometimes they're just kind of
randomly broadcasting information out
there that they think might be useful to
each other and that would light of that
happens on the lily line little send
information that's like hey this is
going on what's up with that okay
knowledge offerings of particularly
interesting categories of behaviors to
look at because unlike seeking where the
person who wants to have information has
to have some idea of who they might go
to in order to get an answer what's
happening here is not the answer is
coming to you you're just saying here's
my problem you're not even necessarily
actively saying here's my problem you're
just trying to work out a problem in the
answer is coming to you from the people
who have that information but less we
immediately rush to convert all of our
teams to XP methods while knowledge on
the FSB team is more transparent in the
moment this knowledge is also less
permanent on the XP TM this loss enos
can be traced back to excuse model of
knowledge retention so XP issues
documentation practices so they don't
write code comments they believe in
writing a self document code stuff
documenting code they don't write design
documents and general the idea is that
the design documents grow too rapidly
out of date to be worth maintaining
technically technical and design
knowledge is therefore quite
deliberately on this
centered primarily on two places in the
minds of the developers on the team and
in the project code artifact it's off
excuse me several XP practices pair
programming particularly the switching
component of pair programming open
workspace the daily stand-up meetings
are intended to facilitate the
communication of knowledge about code
across as many programmers on the team
as possible but the drawback of relying
entirely on the human mind is twofold
first of all the mines lossy knowledge
degrades over time in the absence of
repeated use and if knowledge is
retained only in the minds of others and
that knowledge is inaccessible when
those mines are inaccessible if
someone's physically out of the room you
can't get what at what they know second
mental capacity is far from infinite
like we all can't know everything so the
amount of information as that increases
the amount of information that people
need to retain people begin to get
overloaded and so that even if that
information is readily available through
to them through the practices they may
not retain it is knowledge lossy but is
what is the other thing is steady
acknowledged read it do they have no
image attritional memory kind of and I
try to talk about the ways in which they
kind of make the job easier for
themselves but that there may be not
capturing everything either so to give
examples of this a pattern of behavior
that began to occur fairly regularly
towards the end of my observations with
the XP teams remember I saw them at the
very beginning I saw them and then my
second set was sort of about a year and
a half into their existence was one more
design decision for being
unintentionally revisited and this was
something that I could sort of for the
second half of my observations I would
see at least one instance of every
single day so not enough to do a count
sort of like it's happening but very
significant digits it's happening
repeatedly I'm in the first example here
the redundancy is caught fairly early
here's what happening is Mark is
suggesting a task to repair developers
who actually aren't talking at this
point describing a particular behavior
exhibited by the application that he
feels is really disconcerting and
therefore needs to be fixed and he's got
to say you know you guys go off and
figure out what's wrong with this and he
makes a couple suggestions for how to
change it
what's happening is that Henry who's an
old member of the XP team but has been
promoted actually and so no longer works
their day to day just happens to be
walking through the XP area at the time
here's the tax proposal immediately
stops to correct mark tell me that
actually this particular behavior is
explicitly bad as I and there's been an
extensive conversation about this
behavior and that they decided to go
with this because of this reason so
despite the fact that the papers
requested discussed upon and agreed by
substituting that information is either
been forgotten by the team numbers
involved in that conversation or not
known at all by the people that were
actually present and hence therefore
only serendipitously recovered by the
fact that Henry happened to walk in at
that time in the second example it
doesn't get caught it early so Sam
actually spends half a day working on a
task that turns out to be completely
unnecessary here we see him at the point
where he realizes it he's reading an
error message that you didn't see before
evidently had changed the code base that
directly affects his cast for the day
but that he was unaware of Sam is
actually pretty Rawat XP guy he sort of
went a big like proponents on the team
of the the benefits of this methodology
so what he's trying to sort of weekly
spin it here to both his partner who's
one of the newer members of the team and
me is that it's sort of like an
interesting things about XP what's
happening here but it's really the
team's practice reviewing less effective
at communicating and retaining
information about technical changes due
to the rapid pace of technical change
and as more people come onto the team
and are making changes at the same time
so as Sam puts it here things go so fast
lots of things have changed since I
looked at it last Tuesday you know but
it sure would have helped story 1747 if
he had known that and then later as he
realizes the test that he's been working
on all morning is in his words complete
crap he's sort of cheerfully trying to
note that well we only spent about half
the day on this so it's not the end of
the world but again illustrative effect
that like they're really starting to
lose track of what's going on and sort
of revisiting work that they've already
done yeah all over the team members on
the XP team how old yeah other people
have problems with memory or or lost
memories in here
typically the demographically the median
I did the math I think it's about the
same of the two teams yeah so the XP
team actually probably a little bit
younger slightly any use of like taking
notes so that they should remember for
themselves as memory yes and we're going
to talk about that in like three slides
so so you're saying this kind of self
documenting and then by that they don't
use so many comments they don't really
try to avoid good comments whenever
possible yeah really mm-hmm I didn't
realize that was part of the XP
philosophy so XP philosophy they have
like 14 of 12 official practices they've
added two and then there's like this
whole bunch of other stuff that just
comes along with it that everyone does
so Thomas you're just seen as bad
because they get out of yeah I mean in
some sense that's what I observed on the
waterfall team is they write comments
but when they're reading code they don't
rely on those comments at all like
they'll look at the code they'll be all
these comments and they're like well it
says it does this but who knows if it
actually does that but they do actually
write it yeah was there any design log
that was made of rationale for decisions
on the whole point basis the idea was
that everyone would kind of remember it
because they were all in the same room
and they heard it and at least one
person two people there directly worked
on it so no design log
so in addition to this pair switching
this practice of daylily switching pairs
appears to really be muddying the waters
in addition to this by increasing the
amount of information developers exposed
to as he or her switches in and out of
tasks throughout the week and in terms
of knowledge transfer fidelity and
overload so consider the case of a
module that goes through several days of
observations the very first day Alice
and Bob the first two people will work
on this sit down to implement the
initial design Alice has some initial
conception of the design a bob will get
some very closely overlapping but not
exactly the same conceptual design a
prime on the second day the pair's
switch else moves on to another task and
Bob will continue carrying on with Kerry
to continue the messaging work at the
end of the day carry now has another
overlapping but slightly different
conception and design a they will call
it a prime prime in a week later David
and Ethan are going to sit down and make
another change this module add another
feature and because the XP programmers
go to the very last person who made a
change the model for advice right
they'll go to carry and what they're
going to come away with is a prime prime
prime so as you can see what's happening
is over time understanding on a
particular model gets more and more out
of stink these disconnects in the early
part of the phase during the pilot study
were held in check by the small team
size and the fact that when you only had
about five people and when you're really
starting up the project they could
constantly have team-wide communication
and be aware what's going on but as the
codebase gets more complex and as they
bring more people on the developer
started to complain that the code base
is getting more and more disjointed and
this happened on both the XP teams I saw
um yeah hmm so they did not practice
continuous refactoring they sorta did
that's sort of the one practice that I
see people will say and play lip service
do they do it in the small if you will
like they'll be like this test structure
these three functions really should be
only two functions this will do that
every time but in terms of like these
four modules should be restructured that
didn't happen so much I mean and I would
hear people say like we should really
restructure the modules but kind of the
reality of I need to deliver the project
meant that you know and it doesn't the
customer you can't see that new
functionality exciting have a good topic
they have full support for refactoring
or
the manual process they used your clips
think ID one of those two but it had a
lot of refractories were built into it
so yeah they didn't have to make all the
changes by him so what I heard people
saying in the course of interviews were
just observations is complaining to each
other that the code base was getting
really messy and they actually
pinpointed explicitly on to the fact
that different understandings of
particular modules are being coded into
the overall code base then people would
actually complain that for instance like
this modules interaction with this
particular messaging module doesn't make
sense or isn't quite right they don't
quite understand what's going on here so
they've written all this code and now we
have to either go back and change it or
just in the fact that it's a huge mess
for them and one developer specifically
said to me that this is not a code base
I'm proud of this is not something that
I would show people on an interview
because I'm not because it's so messy on
the waterfall team there's a slower pace
of change and a strict division of
technical responsibility on the
developers that makes this a little bit
easier the right form of divine
documents as I mentioned before written
circulated amongst the team once the
documents are completed in the approval
process for your design is completed the
documents are rarely referred to even in
the case of implementation so it's sort
of the active writing seems to be what's
going on here and making everyone see it
for that first time but the document
provides a base for the common
understanding of the design it's very
clearly like this is what we're going to
do this is the goal in addition a single
developer is responsible for the
entirety of a particular clap a task
along with the longer task development
times there means there are fewer ships
for an individual developer between
tasks they usually have one thing it's
going to range from three days to two
weeks and that's all they do for that
three days unless chant lest attract
means less redundant work developers
also have a higher fidelity
understanding the code because they
usually return to the code itself when
learning about new areas of the project
so the XP team they usually go to the
person to get an explanation of what's
going on and run with that but on the
waterfall team they would actually
themselves return to the code they would
only use people as a pointer to find out
which parts of the code they should
really be looking at but then they would
actually specifically go very carefully
read through what was happening and get
their own understanding of how the code
worked same with any new check-ins to
the system on the XP side what you do is
you tell everyone in the next morning
the stand up meeting
you made this particular change you give
like the three line summary of what the
implications of the change were and
until you actually went looked at that
change or had to directly lose that code
you hadn't just took their word for it
if you weren't the person who made that
on the waterfall team whatever check-ins
occur actually everyone on the team very
carefully reads through the exact line
of code so I kind of impressed by this
whenever a check in half and you get all
these messages afterwards that were like
oh i see this i fixed it for you you
know here's this other thing that you
should maybe tweet so there's a much
higher fidelity of the information or
getting about the code but at the cost
of much much greater effort right
basically everyone's relearning
everything from starch well rarely
revisit the design documents what does
that mean it means that after they write
it and send it out and go through that
process of like you know talking about
what the features are and they say go
you're good just implement what you've
written they put that document into a
CVS repository and no one ever touches
it again except when I say was there a
design document and they pull it out and
they send it to me yeah but it's only
live for that process only even though
they do go to great expense to maintain
a cache of documentation on their memory
as well how loss is that memory of the
design um that's something I really
didn't get a chance to track in the same
way that the ex piece I did but they
look if you're the database person
you're like the data first person for a
year right so you're not swapping off as
much so my sense was that like you're
making all the database related changes
so you're getting a chance to use that
knowledge much more rapidly right so
it's not the same situation where one
day your UI one day your database one
day you're you know networking which is
it on the XP team so the way I tried to
get at those this sort of imperfect
matter but I think it still shows a kind
of interesting pattern is it these two
tasks tiles in these practices are
reflected in the pattern of what the
knowledge on the developers on the two
teams record so this slide presents
break down all the observed knowledge
recording events and what I do is I kind
of categorize them by the intended
knowledge or sorry intended audience
with recorded knowledge so are they
writing this for the group is large for
another person or for themselves it
turns out they really right
explicitly for other people so I kind of
committed that category and the intended
duration of their corded not so is it a
formal design document that's intended
to be archived in the long term or is it
just in a set of documents that you've
written or sir I serve like a to-do list
for instance that's going to carry over
you for the next couple days or is it
something that you're just writing out
right now to work through the logic and
so the the time concision that was if it
was greater than a week I considered a
long term it was greater than a couple
hours I considered to be a short term
but less than a week and if it was a
couple minutes then I considered that
and nearly all the events fell into
three buckets the three they're
presented here only two of the 150
events was outside of these two
categories and again what you see a
really clear differences by team the
developers on the x team externalized
most of their knowledge for personal
short-term use and long-term group use
whereas by far the majority of the
externalization events on the waterfall
team or for long-term group use
reflecting in their practice of
documenting things formally for other
people so the XE fair gamers don't write
up so much stuff to the whole team but
they're writing an awful awful lot of
stuff down for themselves oh that's
happening all groupid that are so mm-hmm
that's a great long-term okay so you
consider those long-term even though
they don't but what do you mean by
checking i mean this big christmas love
so so i do a check-in i explain why and
like a CVS no decision yet yeah that
sounds a long term group in listen oh
because they actually have to explicitly
write a message in there yeah what's
interesting is that actually the long
term group on the XP side includes
officer tekken messages which they also
write every single time but they never
ever read them versus the waterfall team
actually reads every single one yeah
where do you categorize broadcast over
Lily from the waterfall team that won
was kind of dicey and I end up using I
ended up putting it in the communication
category rather than in explicitly
recorded knowledge
if anybody ever go back there's a short
archive and so I figured when you're
sending things over Lily you're more it
functions more as a speech act than it
does as a written I'm documenting that
but I kind of went back and forth on it
a little while so you could categorize
it the lot of the distinction between
externalized knowledge and communication
draws on these kind of old theories of
knowledge right that haven't really
caught up to the fact that now we have
email and all this other stuff so but
that's what I based on so these styles
it's like the waterfall team should want
to change their schedule every few
months or their project and the XP team
you want but I'm not alone three-year
project two to mismatch as much as
possible yeah so it's particularly lets
you hone the XP team is more than double
to take a little bit more about these
the relevant category the XP team does
more than double the personal short-term
notes that the waterfall does that's
percentage wise and the majority of
these short-term personal instances are
them recording information about their
current task so usually they're saying
what else do I need to do on this I need
to follow up on this issue later on I
need this is this code solution that we
did is in perfect then you didn't
remember to tell people that we did this
this and this or what else do I have to
do before I finish and what's
particularly striking about this
practice that's not reflected here is
the consistency with which all the
programmers on the XP team make these
sorts of notes on the waterfall team
people make notes like that too but it's
actually highly variable is
idiosyncratic some people make a lot of
notes some people make no notes some
people make a few notes on the XP team
everyone makes a lot of nodes which
suggests that the variation on the
waterfall seam is sort of consistent
with individual variation in mental
capacity right some people just have a
leisure time remembering what they have
to do and some people don't versus the
uniformity of the practice on the XP
side suggests a much more systemic cause
that there's something about the XP
practices it just makes it harder for
people to remember task information
another pretty interesting thing that's
happening there is that the XP team
never records information about past has
progress so I did SI waterfall team
member shank task task progress so in
the middle of the task the waterfall
teams I saw people saying okay well I've
done
this and this so let me write that down
right and I have left this this and this
the XP team never does that they only
say what do we have to go next and this
is again consistent across all the
developers there and I did it between
the constant task switching that the XP
team members engaged in and the smaller
scrip of their task assignment in the
practice of daily switching they simply
have more difficulty remembering task
relevant information but the fact that
they have a pair partner makes it really
easy for them to remember in the moment
what they've already done like they
don't feel the need to write it down
because they can just always ask the guy
who is right next to them who also help
them do it and so that I think is why we
don't ever see that in there so let's
see developers on the waterfall team
record both forms of information
although again much less frequently in
somewhat video sync radically so to
summarize a sort of what I presented
here today the FC practices particularly
parameter open workspace make design
status and technical knowledge more
transparent among members of the XP team
these types of knowledge particularly
status knowledge are less available on
the waterfall team and this is reflected
in a pattern of knowledge seeking
behaviors in terms of implications of
this from kind of generalizing up the
same practices so this is sort of my
ideas I've been thinking about based on
these findings so same practices that
make XP knowledgeable available to each
other also make it available for cat for
capture and this is something I've been
talking with it's got clemmer a little
bit about is like well you're in this
environment where people are constantly
talking so that's design decisions that
that team is losing is audibly available
i mean i know because i have them
captured in my notes right i was sitting
behind them when they were making that
decision and i could see what they were
doing here what they were saying as they
were deciding to do what they're doing
so they're losing it but it's actually
in a way that we could conceivably
capture you know combination of audio
video again I've been talking to Scott
to think about little ways that we can
do this but that information is out
there so there's absolutely no reason
necessary that it should just be lost
the way it's currently be doing and then
on the waterfall side what this does is
it points it kind of an opportunity at
what they're really missing is these
ways to get status about information
about each other is something that they
really need and that they're having to
explicitly ask each other for so there's
sort of a
kind of opportunity for either a
practice or a tool based solution to
that my second summary the implication
XP practice transparency allows the
developers to more accurately for
information to their teammates waterfall
programmers instead direct knowledge
based on what they know about their
teammates activity so the task of their
day or the projects and as I said they
have morning meetings they kind of know
what everyone's task is for the day and
that's what they're using to make those
judgments um one thing that this really
shows is that this opposite approach to
knowledge sharing problem instead of one
where you're making it easier for people
to search for the answer right this idea
that if you make the problem that
they're doing sort of passively
available to everyone else that the
answer can actually maybe come to you
and I think this is a paradigm that
hasn't really been really flushed out in
many of the tool designs that we've been
thinking about in terms of improving
knowledge sharing activities so I think
that might be a really interesting space
to start thinking about how can we
structure the tools that we have or even
the practice that we have to kind of
encourage that more in different
environments despite this transparency
the knowledge on the XP team is less
permanent or more Lassie they kind of
point this to the idea that the XP model
of collective knowledge retention rest
on this may be flawed assumptions about
the human mind and this knowledge loss
is reflected in the increase in
redundant work overtime task information
overload and higher and a more systemic
rate of recording of tasks related
knowledge and so taken together to
suggest that shorter task scope and pair
rapid switches may not be such a good
idea sexy people like to say okay all
the practices need to come together but
with these studies are starting to
really show is maybe that's actually not
working for you you've got a lot of
really good things going on but here are
a couple practices that really are
hurting you more than there actually
helping
where you might want to change your
practice that from XP to sort of
waterfall or something in between I
hadn't done that yet but I think that's
a very logical next step in terms of
what we're trying to build to write like
I think that that I talked a lot of XP
developers and they've never considered
their right like they buy the whole kit
and caboodle and it's like that you know
what I mean if you think about like what
I want to do when I'm a teenager I don't
want to do one of my adult hmm things
change and you would think like a piece
of software code when it's green field
and it's being just when the design
isn't clear and you know that's its
youth and then when it gets a little bit
more mature it needs a need something
else so seems yeah I mean I think that's
totally what I've tried part of the
bigger picture that I'm building towards
missing yeah right like it makes sense
like if you like it again here's where i
go back to like organizational theory
has like they have models for that when
you transition past certain
organizational forms right they say like
there's a hierarchy model that is when
your end organization is bigger there's
sort of like these different models that
they have a very specific transition
between organizations sides and these
whole other factors like you know
contingencies in the environment and
environmental change but like that's not
really part of how we're thinking about
software development so I've sort of
like headed there but starting the first
step of being like well here's how the
practices seem to be contributing on
this team what does that say about what
those factors might be design sir yeah
it strikes me I'm sorry oh I should stop
comfortable okay uh-huh were you able to
get any data on delivered defect
densities no like I said that's couldn't
get the the bug tracking or CVS data
we've done something by these three
years and we don't need you to the small
project so that in the range of stage 2
15 people total and we have a defect
rate so we shift to be in terms of lines
of code
it is a logical for partek brightening a
similar amount of code for the unit
tests and our experience had been
there's one or two set ones anything to
the out of that without binding
codes using XP well it's a modified
version your example we we do not let
people swap 3d right so we have people
focus on an area and they stay and then
we'll pull people in we don't be on
appropriate programming when it's really
complex we want to pair program it's
just kind of like an area so it's ok I
would say it's a modified version but it
we value exists and we have we do pair
programming but it's not I would say
it's probably twenty to thirty percent
of the time than at any parties is too
incredible man thank you yeah see you
look at one XD project in one waterful
project but sometimes you have actually
a larger project where some part of the
team works in XP another part of the
theme works applies wonderful typically
when you work with hardware guys though
they design a wonderful I was wrong
weather looking at your study you can
reflect upon what type of practices
would recommend to make this the
integration of an XP team with a
waterfall team useful yeah um the one
that I recommended that the XP team
really didn't like to use systems that
would make their knowledge I mean they
didn't like to capture knowledge in any
form a formal way like they were sort of
pushed by the company to use the bug
tracking system that everyone else did
because they're subject to the same
support teams right that the rest of the
company's is and they were driving
support crazy because they would never
document any bugs or respond to any bug
reports on there so I think having
shared systems is really important in
terms of practices it's a bit hard to
generalize from this team because I
think they were a bit exceptionally
isolated for XP team like I did go out
and try to look at a couple other XP
teams in order to make sure that what I
wasn't seeing was so crazy in terms of
the practices like four in something you
guys just said that you do a bit
slightly different thing you don't
switch pairs every day and they were
probably again more isolated from the
rest of the company so it's hard to talk
about what they would do
to integrate a little better their whole
structure was set up to be like their
little world and they kind of poked with
integrating with other people by forcing
them to kind of come into the XP model
which he saw with the QA and sort of the
project management they sort of said
come being our cube and it was like sort
of by Fiat it was just such a pain for
them to get work done if they weren't in
the actual area that at the end of the
day they moved in which I would not say
is the optimal strategy but that's one
of the things I was actually interested
in I ate a lot of questions about how
does XP play kind of with the rest of
the company and I think this particular
study just doesn't lend itself to asking
answering those questions because they
just didn't you know it was my way or no
way at all on this team before we run
out of time busting chance hey